the job of the white house press
secretary
is to take questions from the press and
then
answer them and when the press secretary
doesn't want to answer the questions
her job is to answer different questions
and thereby evade the questions that she
was asked but our current white house
press secretary
jenn saki cannot do either of those
things
so instead she circles back
i can i'll circle back if there's more i
can share with you but i'll circle back
with you if there's more to convey um
i'll have to just circle back with you
and we can circle backwards i'm happy to
circle back with you
i can circle back i will have to circle
back on that one that's an excellent
question
oh such an important question uh we will
circle back with you and we'll circle
back with you it's an interesting
question but uh
we'll circle back i'm happy to circle
back but i'll have to circle back with
you on it's a good question but we'll
circle back with you on this today we
will certainly circle back with you more
directly
i hate to disappoint you but i will have
to circle back with you on that as well
no disappointment at all jen i know you
gotta circle back
we will circle back on all the things
that she doesn't want to tell us about
i'm michael knowles this the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday is from
bpow246 who says
i keep forgetting that joe biden won a
fair
election and is now president
fortunately
youtube is here every day underneath the
michael knowles show to remind me
they do i didn't even realize they did
this but underneath my shows it'll it'll
say very often
joe biden won the election and it was
fair and don't question anything about
the election
you just think you know that's the sign
of a really confident ruling class
you know the ruling class is so
confident
that the election is totally fair and
square and nobody has any questions
about it
that they need to tell us every single
day every place that they possibly
can they seem a little insecure
now if you want to feel secure you've
got to check out lifelock that is the
way to protect your data online
scammers are using news of the second
stimulus to steal
americans personal information some
common scams include offers to get your
payment faster
fake checks or unsolicited messages by
someone claiming to be from the irs
links within these emails or text
messages could be dangerous malware or
phishing scams
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised
they will send you an alert and you have
access to a dedicated restoration
specialist
if you become a victim i know that
you're thinking nobody's coming after my
information they
are they are that that is exactly what
they want you to think that nobody's
coming after but they are now obviously
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions at all
businesses
but you can keep what's yours with
lifelock identity theft protection
join now and save up to 25 off your
first year go to lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com knowles for
25 percent off
lifelock.com knowles
head on over check out lifelock
conservatives have been having some fun
at jensaki's expense
because of the incessant promises
to circle back and just in my own
experience maybe if you've heard this
phrase
some there are similar phrases that
people just throw out and they
sell oh we're going to follow up hey you
know we're just we're going to follow up
and we're going to circle back
and synergy and i don't know all this
kind of jargon that millennials use
the thing about circling back is nobody
ever circles back they only say that
because they don't have the answer
and then they leave the meeting or
whatever and that's it and hopefully
they never have to answer it again
so we were all making fun of jensaki for
this on the internet
apparently she took note because
now she finally did decide to circle
back
and last thing i just want to do before
we get to your questions um i often note
i'm going to circle back i hate to
disappoint conservative twitter but i am
going to circle back on a number of
things as we often do directly
yeah you're going to go circle back now
because we all made fun of you because
you never circled back
that's what we we made you do this we
conservatives of twitter
where uh jensaki obviously was scrolling
and scrolling and
i think maybe got we got under her skin
a little bit in a way i miss those
halcyon days when
jensaki would just not answer any
questions because
when she gives us the answers to
questions those answers
are pretty radical one example
this in the continued persecution of
donald trump
who they're still trying to convict in
his impeachment trial after he's left
office
if that doesn't work i'm sure they're
going to go after him in the southern
district of new york or some other sort
of court
now they're trying to take away his
intelligence briefing so it has been a
custom
for a very long time in this country
that former presidents receive
intelligence briefings and
uh many presidents avail themselves of
this opportunity you know it's part of
the honor that goes with the office
and to keep them involved in the public
life now
many members of the press and the
administration
are suggesting that we deny trump his
daily
intelligence briefings here is the
softball question
has the white house made a determination
about whether it will continue to extend
the privilege of intelligence briefings
to former president trump
given the concerns among some democrats
that he'll either misuse it or leverage
it to enrich himself
this is a good question i've raised it
with our intelligence teams or our
national security team i should say it's
something obviously that's under review
but
there was not a conclusion unless i
asked him about it but i'm happy to
follow up on it and see if there's more
to share
just think about how much of a
sort of democrat propaganda that
reporter was able to cram into that one
question
uh yes jen uh do you know is the white
house going to extend
the privilege not the tradition
not the right the privilege of
intelligence briefings to trump
given that you know some democrats
namely
me uh worry that he could use this to
undermine the administration enrich
himself or
collude with russia or collude i don't
know whatever nonsense
and she says wow yeah what a great
question oh my goodness wow
so smart we're looking at that we're
looking into it we're circling back
everywhere my reaction
first reaction to this is are the press
and the members of this administration
are they trying to deny trump his
intelligence briefings because they
think he's totally not popular at all
and he definitely lost that election you
know without any sort of irregularities
whatsoever and is that is that why
they're
seems to me they're pretty afraid of the
guy it seems to me they think
he might still be sort of popular seems
to me they think that their grasp on
power
is a little tenuous but then
beyond that which you know we're seeing
that all the time and all the
constant signs from the administration
no questions with the election you know
all over big tech you see this
the capital i think is still under uh
under uh guard all over the place with a
giant wall you can't possibly get in
there now
beyond that do you think donald trump is
an intelligence risk donald trump
discovered
many problems in the intelligence
community he discovered that the
intelligence community
was illegally spying on the political
opponents of the dominant regime
he discovered that there was massive
abuse from
obama biden associates through the fisa
process
he discovered that there were all sorts
of problems with the ic
a lot of people got fired because of it
but do you think trump himself is i
guess if you believe that trump is
colluding with the russians or something
then you think he's in
a security risk we had a multi-year
mueller investigation you remember that
remember that saga it's mueller time and
they concluded
that there was no collusion with the
russians whatsoever
however there is some collusion with the
russians from the new administration
namely there's a photo of
jen saki herself standing with john
kerry
standing with some russian dude
wearing a giant russian hat with a
hammer and sickle on it i'm not joking
she's got the symbol of the communist
party
on her hat she's wearing it this was
apparently a gift from the russian
delegation
and jensaki foolishly put it on her head
and took a picture
do you think that the russians didn't
realize this would be very embarrassing
for the americans
to have this official wearing a
communist
hammer and sickle hat but they did it
anyway ha ha that's that's how we'll
reset our relationship
if anybody in this situation is the
security risk
one guy donald trump the one who hugs
and kisses the american flag
one lady the person wearing a hammer and
sickle on her head in russia
gotta tell you i don't think it's donald
trump
the other things she's saying just as
radical perhaps more radical
jen was asked about president trump
his twitter account and the question of
big tech censorship more broadly
as you know president trump has been
barred from a lot of social media sites
it's curious whether you think his
absence has made your job any easier or
the white house's job any easier as it
kind of
goes forward on these coveted
negotiations in what way
well he created a lot of noise right he
would he would have certain
gravitational pull with republicans who
may be um
may be more inclined to take a harder
position i wonder if that's
been anything that you guys have thought
about or kind of considered
this may be hard to believe we don't
spend a lot of time talking about our
thinking about president trump here
former president trump
to be very clear ha ha she did it too
she did that same thing that joe biden
did
joe biden just the other day was saying
well you know i was talking to the
president
uh uh i mean the former president trump
the freudian slip is where you say one
thing but you mean your mother jen saki
just did the same thing
my broader take on the question though
is goodness gracious
white house press corps get a room get a
uh hey jen oh yes johnny
uh isn't it awesome that trump's off
twitter well johnny you'll have to be
more specific what's awesome about it
well you know he's bad and
he's orange and bad wow great question
you know but i don't even think about
him hahaha giggle giggle
she goes on though to actually address
the substance of this question
and i don't think we're gonna like it i
think that's a question that's probably
more appropriate for
republican members who are looking for
ways to support a bipartisan package
and whether that gives them space but i
can't say we miss him on twitter
does president obama support the
continuing ban of president trump on
their sites
i think that's a decision made by
twitter we certainly spoken to and he's
spoken to
um the need for social media platforms
to continue to take steps to
reduce hate speech but we don't have
more for you on it than that
the question was does joe biden think
that his predecessor should be
de-platformed kicked off of social media
her answer was
that is a decision that facebook and
twitter made
which is true but the question was what
is your boss's opinion on that
what is your boss's opinion on the
handful of silicon valley oligarch
billionaires
who have the power to censor the then
sitting
duly elected president of the united
states
don't you think that might be an issue
that the the current sitting president
of the united states
might be able to weigh in on but she
doesn't want to answer it
because of course biden does support
trump's continued de-platforming because
they're never going to de-platform biden
they're never going to de-platform
democrats they're going to de-platform
republican presidents
and she goes on she actually underscores
this right she says
joe biden he's talked about how we need
vigorous hate speech policies
and i know conservatives react to this
phrase hate speech
kind of a knee-jerk reaction because we
know what the left means by that
what they mean is generally ridiculous
but i do think conservatives need to
re rethink how we're talking about
cancer culture how we're talking about
deep platforming
how we're talking about censorship and
how we're talking about free speech
because i think we're actually getting
this topic wrong
and it's and the fact that we are
getting it wrong is what is allowing the
left to just run
absolute roughshod over us and claim
that every single thing they don't like
at all
up to and including christian doctrine
sort of broad points about the moral
order that is all hate speech you're not
allowed
to say it and we don't want to listen to
that when we do listen though we should
be using raycon
raycon oh my goodness gracious what a
superior product
these days it feels like we are always
looking at a screen
now i think more than ever whether
you're an avid news watcher maybe you're
in serious need of a distraction from
the news
unplugging yourself is easier said than
done one of the best ways to rest your
eyes
and still get the content that you're
itching for is by putting in
raycon wireless earbuds and listening to
something
great maybe you're catching up on your
favorite podcast
i don't know maybe you're binging an
audiobook maybe you're powering through
your workout
with a pumped up playlist a pair of
rakons in your ears
can make all the difference raycon's now
offering
15 off all their products for my
listeners
here is what you got to do to get it you
got to go to buy raycon.com
knowles these earbuds look great they
feel really comfortable they're
extraordinarily stylish
they are a superior product to maybe
other offerings you're seeing on the
market all right
enough said you'll get 15 off your
entire rakon order so feel free to grab
a pair and a spare
fifteen percent off at byraycon.com
knowles
buy raycon.com knowles go
check them out now wireless earbuds they
are super super
cool one example of
hate speech according to the left
would be a christian news organization
that was just suspended from twitter
for saying that men cannot be women the
daily citizen
which is a part of focus on the family
it's a sort of right-wing conserva
christian group engaged in quote hateful
rhetoric
according to twitter because this is
what they tweeted out
you know that joe biden has chosen for
one of his senior
health and human services officials a
man who believes that he's a woman and
presents himself as a woman
so this is what the daily citizen
tweeted out quote on tuesday
president-elect joe biden announced that
he had chosen dr rachel levine to serve
as assistant secretary for health at the
department of hhs
dr levine is a transgender woman that is
a man who believes he's a woman
that's hates you're not allowed to say
that now you may recall
a couple years ago now i had a speaking
tour a national
speaking tour called the men are not
women and other uncomfortable truths
tour
and i was giving various speeches on
things that are perfectly common sense
such as
uh babies or people you know things like
that
when i gave the men or not women's
speech i was screamed at the entire time
at a full first 20 minutes of the speech
and then someone comes out with a super
soaker and
sprays me with some noxious sort of
substance uh then the
cops got him out of there or any leaves
now
this issue has caused a lot of
consternation on the left
and i think it's caused so much
consternation because it's so
undeniable men are not women
men cannot become women simply by
wishing it so or by dressing like a
woman or putting on lipstick in high
heels
now in order to effect the gender
ideology that the left wants
in the face of this the clear
things that we're seeing with our own
eyes the face of this obvious
truth they have to censor you and they
think that by censoring you by changing
the words by changing the speech codes
they will thereby be able to alter
reality
and this is the kind of hate speech
policy that the left wants to pursue
this ties in with something that we
refer to as cancel culture
ethan hawke who is not a conservative by
any stretch of the imagination
ethan hawk just came out against cancel
culture too he's plugging this new novel
that he's written
and he said quote in the light of cancel
culture and shaming while a lot of this
moment's very helpful it's a difficult
time to say
i want to be open about the
idiosyncrasies of human sexuality
he's got this book a bright ray of
darkness where he's talking about
confused sexuality and he says you know
well if you talk about sex too much
today you could get canceled
and because of this cancer culture we've
got to watch what we say so what we have
to do is cancel cancer culture
then once you cancel cancer culture then
we can all say what we want
i think conservatives need to be a
little more specific here
obviously there is something called
cancel culture it's a
discrete phenomenon it's what happens
right now when
the left destroys your career destroys
your livelihood
ostracizes you from society for
contradicting
leftist politically correct orthodoxy
that's specifically what it is
nobody's getting canceled for being too
conservative
right no nobody's getting canceled for
criticizing communism
okay people are getting cancelled for
criticizing the dictates of
radical leftist political correctness
for saying that men
men cannot become women
we have fallen into the trap that we
continue to fall
into through political correctness
woke-ism cancel culture it's all
they're all basically describing the
same phenomenon
political correctness replaces the old
moral standard
with new speech codes a moral code
becomes a speech code and in so doing
the left upends society
react to this one of two ways generally
speaking
either they acquiesce they bend the knee
they're the squishy republicans who go
along with political correctness and
follow the dictates of cancer culture
and just say what the left wants them to
say
or they abandon standards altogether and
they say i'm a free speech
purist i think you should be able to say
whatever you want
i think and everybody should be able to
say exactly what he thinks
and doesn't matter how radical or how
subversive or how threatening or how
fraudulent
and he should face absolutely no
consequences from that and
both of those reactions are wrong and
the even the latter which i think most
conservatives are taking right now
is giving the left an opportunity
because what the left is doing is
they're going in and they're saying wait
a second
you were perfectly fine ostracizing
people for holding this view
or silencing people for holding this
view or firing people for holding this
view
when it suited your purposes but now
now that it's going in the other
direction now that we're doing it to
people for saying conservative things
that's totally wrong i don't think you'd
find any conservative
out there who would say that if some guy
walks into his employer
and and yells kyle hitler that the
employer has some right not to fire him
or rather that the employee has some
right not to be fired
right that the the employer doesn't have
the right to fire him
i don't think anyone would suggest that
if you walk into i don't know a
government job or
into your public school and you start
screaming heil hitler
that you can't face some punishment for
that some consequence is that
cancel culture well it's not cancer
because when we talk about cancer
culture we're talking about
what's happening right now this very
discreet leftist phenomenon but broadly
speaking of course we have standards
of course we think people should face
consequences for the things that they
say
bill buckley used to he was the sort of
founder of the modern conservative
movement
as mainstream as they get founded
national review
hosted firing line the longest running
public affairs program with a single
host in television history
bill buckley totally orbained totally
acceptable he was doing an interview
in 1966 on his show firing line and they
were discussing mccarthyism and
talk about the original cancel culture
mccarthyism really gets into it but it
was in the other direction
and the guest of bill buckley's on the
show
said wait a second bill if you're in any
way defending joe mccarthy
that means you're not for a totally open
society
you're not for free speech absolutism
you're not for the perfectly open
marketplace of ideas
and bill buckley the as mainstream of
conservative as it gets came out and he
said
of course i'm not the society must be
closed
to certain ideas because as i
read you listen to you speak with you
the open society is an urgently
necessary aspect of
all that we both value i don't agree no
i don't want the society to be open to
certain ideas
uh i i am phil i i am an epistemological
optimist uh as the unfortunate way they
use
to describe people who believe that by
reason
you can make certain exclusions and
those exclusions don't have to be
reconsidered
i don't feel any obligation to protect
the liberties of a nazi
or or of a communist or as for that
matter anybody who seeks class
legislation
or genocidal warfare between people so i
want it to be closed
at least to that extent of course
and by the way every society has been
closed to some extent
because societies are finite things
because language is a finite thing
if i call a man a man if we all agree
the man is a man then the man cannot be
a woman
if the man can be a woman then we are
talking about totally different things
we use words in society to communicate
to one another so that we use these
symbols of words
to refer to real things but if the words
that we're using
cannot be known what they refer to
if it cannot be known what we mean by a
certain word then we can't communicate
with one another and we can't have a
society
and this is true at the very basic level
of what words mean
and it's true at a higher level of what
we all believe what binds us together
what we're all doing here as a country
we have to share certain things this is
why we've had
broad prohibitions against seditious
speech
against uh subversion from the very
beginning of the country and it's taken
different forms over the years but we've
always had it
is it because our founding fathers were
authoritarian
fascist not no it's because they
understand that all speech regimes
have to be somewhat constrained because
this is a finite world so
what does that mean for us it means we
need to be
i think more honest with the left we are
not saying that we have no standards
whatsoever and we can all say whatever
we want and we'll descend into
meaningless cacophony
all in the name of free speech which
ironically of course if we're just
spouting nonsense and words have no
meaning it's the opposite of
free speech right we've totally
undermined free speech we need to be
more honest with the left and with
ourselves and say no we stand for
certain things
it's not merely enough to stand for free
speech we have to stand
for something to say it's this gets back
to something we were talking about
yesterday
with ryan anderson over the ethics and
public policy center it's
not enough to say we stand for religious
liberty sure religious liberty is a
great thing
free speech is a great thing we also
have to say we stand for what we believe
what do we believe what are we doing
here as a country
where are the the boundaries the
inevitable boundaries of society
where are they going to be is it going
to be on locism
and gender radicalism and pumping kids
full of hormones to convince little boys
their little girls and that's going to
be
the acceptable realm of speech or is it
going to be in the other direction
little boys can't become little girls
and we're not going to confuse them and
we're going to love our country we're
not going to burn our flag
we're going to have a more traditional
moral order which one they're mutually
exclusive we can't have a society that
simultaneously holds all of those ideas
it requires courage to come out and say
what we actually believe
requires courage and conviction buckley
said this very well and god and man at
yale buckley
buckley pointed out something that we
all used to know to be true
skepticism has utility only when it
leads to conviction
what is our conviction
what is our conviction speaking of
convictions ben is going to be talking
about
the impeachment trial and whether or not
trump is going to be convicted
on his show so be sure to stay tuned for
that you know earlier this month we
released our first film run hide fight
exclusively for daily wire members
the audience loved it i loved it i loved
watching it i
we got to do a premiere here with the
director and the producer was a lot of
fun
the critics they did not love it this
was a politically incorrect film
wasn't agitprop wasn't conservative
propaganda it just wasn't woke
so they hated it they didn't want it to
get distribution so we distributed it
you can get it at dailywrite.com
on our mobile app or on our streaming
apps apple tv
roku if you're not a daily wire member
yet use promo code rh you have to get 25
off that is rhf for 25 off we'll be
right back with a lot more
we always have speech codes
the speech codes used to be that you
couldn't openly avow your allegiance to
the
communist party in soviet russia that
might have some
professional consequences for you that
would incur some appropriate
now the speech codes mean
that even if you're a duly elected
senator you're not allowed to criticize
the vice president of the united states
if the vice president
is a member of certain protected and
aggrieved identity groups
this we just learned from kamala harris
really we learned it from whoopi
goldberg describing
a an interaction between kamala harris
and joe manchin so joe manchin
is the sort of moderate democrat from
west virginia kamala harris
radical democrat most radical member of
the senate back when she was
fully a senator now she's the vice
president but she'll also vote in the
senate
obviously they don't agree on a lot of
things so kamala harris did something
that was pretty
tough by political measures they're
trying to work out this
new stimulus deal and
kamala harris went down to go on local
television in west virginia
and arizona two states where the
democrats are a little bit more
conservative
to go circumvent those slightly more
conservative democratic senators
and try to convince the voters in those
states themselves
and put pressure on those senators to go
vote for the biden harris plan
without even talking to people like
cinema in arizona
or at joe manchin in west virginia
so joe manchin was very upset about this
and he expressed his displeasure on tv
i saw it i couldn't believe it no one
called me we're going to try to find a
bipartisan pathway forward i think we
need to
but we need to work together that's not
a way of working together what was done
fair enough it's not like he was out
there throwing bombs but he came out and
he said you know this
this was really unprofessional uncalled
for
you know pick up the phone let me know
what's going on don't go behind my back
to try to turn my voters against me
whoopi goldberg was very offended not by
what kamala harris did
but by what joe manchin did okay so let
me just point this
out joe uh
she is the vice president she does not
work for you she doesn't need your
permission to go do this
and when you talk like that it sounds a
little bigoted like
you think you have the right to tell her
when she can and cannot come someplace
so republicans are offering less than a
third of what
president biden requested less money for
emergency
employment benefits smaller checks for
individuals so
why would she need to come to you first
or would come to him first sonny when
she knows what she's supposed to be
talking about
this is such a cheap and lazy political
shot
i i when i'm considering all of the sort
of left-wing commentators out there
whoopi goldberg is one of my favorites i
actually don't i don't consider her the
worst of the worst to me this just seems
like she was
hastily putting her show notes together
and didn't want to take two seconds to
formulate
an interesting and serious thought about
it so she just plays the race card
but it's really really pathetic because
what she's saying is
kamala harris she doesn't work for joe
manchin
well first of all cumulative is the is
the vice president right so she's not
the president
vice president not one of the most
important spots
in the federal government in this
administration she'll be
fairly important because she'll be
casting the tie-breaking vote but the
tie-breaking vote means she's got to
work with senators
right so her job is to work with the
senators
to get consensus and pass legislation
she especially needs to work with
members of her own party the democrats
one way to really undermine all of that
is to go behind their backs and apply a
lot of pressure to them in their own
states without even giving them a heads
up
forget calling them first without even
giving them a heads up
and joe manchin expressing his
displeasure do you think he's displeased
because kamala harris is black do you
think he's displeased because kamala
harris is a woman
no i think he's displeased because she
behaved in a very disrespectful and
unprofessional way
and they're supposed to work together
for the entire administration does
whoopi even believe
that this is about race or sex or
something like that i don't think so i
think it's just so easy
that is the the reflex now because
speaking of standards our new national
standard is this kind of bizarre
racial and sexual caste system whereby
you can just throw
every sort of complex issue or any kind
of grievance
onto those matters it reminds me of when
david webb the
political commentator he had this woman
on
she was a black left-wing woman and they
were debating some issue
and it was a radio show so so she says
well david you only think that because
of your white privilege
and david starts laughing he said you
know if you knew me lady i i don't think
you'd make that claim she goes no it's
just it's because of your white
privilege
for those who don't know david david
webb is black he is not a white guy
he does not i i don't know him terribly
well but i've spent some time with the
guy
i've never seen any evidence of white
privilege you know dripping out of the
man
so she just said this to him because
it's just a reflex it's easy
sure throw it off that's what whoopi was
doing here and it's it's really really
dangerous for society to be to be
engaging in those sorts of things
it's it's it's so unreasoned it's so
degraded speaking of degradation and a
lack of reason
and the new standards peta is giving us
an even more radical set of standards
peta is very concerned about speciesism
this is a story from last week we didn't
have time to get to it but i think it
actually fits in better with what we're
talking about this week
so peta writes words can create a more
inclusive world
or perpetuate oppression calling someone
an animal as an insult reinforces the
myth that humans are superior to animals
and justified in violating them stand up
for justice by rejecting
supremacist language all gobbledygook
but it gets even crazier
in the image that peta attaches to this
they say using animals as
insults perpetuates speciesism
species it's the new racism i guess or
the new sexism or whatever
instead of chicken say coward
instead of rat say snitch instead of
snake say jerk
instead of pig say repulsive instead of
sloth say lazy because otherwise the
sloth's feelings will be hurt
and that's no good for anybody
most people have been talking about this
and making fun of it as just a kind of
ridiculous example of the extremes of
the left
there is something deeper here that
i think undergirds a far more mainstream
cut of the left
they want us to fight against speciesism
because it reinforces the myth
that humans are superior to animals and
this is sort of
supremacist so to briefly try to
understand what all of that nonsense
means
their argument is this hyper-egalitarian
argument that we can't be supremacists
every not just every person has to be
equal to every person
but every and not just equal as a matter
of sort of
natural rights or spiritual equality
before god but
you know equality of outcome equality of
property equality of condition
but it's not just among people it's
among animals too
that any kind of natural hierarchy the
difference between me
and a cockroach and between the angels
and me
right any kind of natural hierarchy is
uh is is wrong it's illegitimate it's
supremacist
okay obviously that's crazy but you
start with a crazy premise you get to
crazy places
we therefore because we're just the same
as animals right we're no different than
animals
we need to use all of these kinds of
words and we need to
change the meanings of words more
broadly it's kind of the politically
correct project
speech is what distinguishes human
beings from other animals
aristotle wrote about this many many
years ago speech is our distinguishing
characteristic other animals can grunt
and they can make certain sounds and
they
can communicate even sort of in very
very basic ways that are proper to their
nature
but only human beings have speech and
because we have speech we can persuade
one another and we are the political
animal we can discuss
how to live together and debate and have
civilization
great when you
rob words of their meaning when you
utterly
pervert words when you try to use the
distortion of words
to rewrite reality you rob
human beings of our humanity you you do
exactly what peta is trying to do
you lower us to the level of animals of
brutes
which is what has happened to our
politics you'll notice our politics has
become far less reasoned
far less sophisticated over the past
couple of decades
if you look at i mean the classic
example is look at the lincoln douglas
debates
these debates that would last for hours
it wasn't sniping and interrupting each
other with
foul language and jabs and barbs and all
these kind of vulgar things
they were making very very long reasoned
arguments and people would stand there
and listen to them for hours
now if you watch the most recent
presidential debates
you'll see how how degraded it's become
that's because our language has become
very degraded too
our attention span our ability to reason
has become very degraded
as that happens our republican form of
government
starts to crack starts to break as i
said we're sort of coming apart at the
seams
now politics becomes less the the matter
of reasoned groups debating one another
and it becomes the matter of brute
interest we no longer have
high-flying oratory we have grunts and
shouts
and screams and ultimately political
violence in the streets
like animals peta is not just
making some flippant sort of silly
radical comment they are
prophesying what what is happening right
now which is that we are
lowering ourselves to the level of
animals we are giving the left exactly
what they want
and society does not seem the better for
it at least
from my vantage now there is at least
one
area of disagreement between a leftist
interest group
and the liberal establishment
namely the liberal establishment
wants us to eat bugs they do
they do don't doubt me on this i'm not
being hyperbolic
obviously i think peta would take some
issue with this with eating bugs but the
the liberal sort of mainstream
neoliberal globalized left
has been trying to get us to eat bugs
for many years the economist just ran a
headline on this
the economist a classic sort of
center-left liberal
magazine they say yes
we still think the world should be
eating more insects
still not convinced we explain why bugs
are coming to a table near you
in the world in 2021 notice this
language this is always the language you
hear from
the mainstream left it's this language
of inevitability
but we think you should eat bugs oh
you're not convinced well we're going to
tell you why you
will eat bugs not why you will want to
eat bugs
not why you will choose to eat bugs but
you will
eat the bugs this has led to a meme on
the internet
that people have sent around which is i
will not live
in pods i will not live i will not eat
the bugs
and i will not consume i will you know
this kind of
this kind of caricature of neoliberal
modern society whereby
we're all locked in our tiny little
apartments and we can't really go
outside and we're supposed to just work
from home
and we can get everything delivered to
us and we're probably probably don't
even own our apartments we're just
probably renting them
and we're not gonna eat you know really
inefficient sort of fancy nice meals
we're going to eat the most utilitarian
efficient way to get nutrients and
that's going to be good it'll be good
for the environment it'll be good for
society we're going to eat the bugs
and we're going to consume whatever
mass-produced products through
globalized trade are given to us
because it'll be cheap and that's
progress and that's modernity
it doesn't sound like the sort of future
that i want to live in
does it you know when when people today
when all the advanced modern people talk
about oh in the dark ages
people lived they had this horrible life
oh in the middle ages
and in antiquity it was so terrible
you mean antiquity with the roman empire
you mean the middle ages of
the height of christendom the height of
western art and architecture
we were building beautiful gothic
cathedrals instead of hideous modern
architectural
blights on our on our landscape they're
so ugly and disgusting i mean that
you mean the antiquity in middle ages
where there was a cultivated sense of
taste
rather than eating the bugs rather than
this kind of sterilized modern culture
i'm not engaging in nostalgia by the way
nostalgia they say is when is history
after a few drinks
i'm not saying everything was better in
the past and nothing's better in the
present there have been many
uh great changes that have happened in
modernity
you know more people are fed they're
sort of better fed even for getting the
bugs for a second
there's certain things that are nice
about modernity
but overall i don't i don't think it's
this perfect wonderful era that's
uniformly better than the past in many
ways it's much much
worse than the past now a lot of people
are saying in response to the economist
article
and these many protestations that we're
all going to eat bugs a lot of people
are saying
i won't eat the bugs i'll never eat the
bugs
let me ask you something if they can
make you wear a mask
or two masks wherever you go in society
always like you're some sort of bandito
or you're wearing a full burka
if they can lock us up in our pods for
months and months and months at a time
and not let us go out and not let us
socialize and cancel thanksgiving
and cancel christmas and sort of cancel
election day by totally upending our
electoral system
in the weeks and months before the
election through in some cases
unconst explicitly unconstitutional
measures
you really think they won't make you eat
the bugs you really think they won't
find a way to inject
sort of new regulations into our
agricultural system that strongly
encourages the use of
bugs or something i'm using a sort of
intentionally
outlandish example to show
society has been extraordinarily upended
over the past year alone but certainly
over the last 10 or 20 years
how how would you ever conclude that
it's just going to stop
why would you conclude that it's just
going to stop
there is hope for reopening society
at least we're told this by the geniuses
at the cdc
after almost a year of school closures
and social closures
the cdc is coming out in a paper that
was just recently published
saying that schools are operating
in-person learning with appropriate
antiviral precautions
have seen only quote scant transmission
of the virus
according to a number of studies
conducted in districts across the
country
so all these teacher unions these lazy
overpaid teacher unions in chicago and
elsewhere
who don't want to go back to work the
great heroes don't want to go back to
work
there's no evidence for that that's not
based up based by the science
finally the scientists are telling us
good we can sort of restart
society how do you restart society
how do you do it you you've shut down
the country for a year you've you've
totally reordered how we all get along
together
you've reordered how we conduct our
government
you've reordered our political or social
or even or even our familial world
loved ones aren't allowed to see one
another we're not allowed to bury our
dead we're not allowed to celebrate
occasions we're not allowed to get
married we're not allowed to do anything
or at least we're strongly discouraged
from doing all those things
how do you just reopen you can't it's so
much easier
to destroy these things it's so much
easier to break society
than it is to get it going again this is
a central conservative insight
very easy to destroy very difficult to
build
and cynical politicians have spent the
last year
really at a broader sense they've spent
the last hundred years but in a very
very tangible way they've spent the last
year destroying
society we're just gonna flip a switch
and it's gonna we're all gonna go back
then
i don't think so i think the tail on
this thing is going to be very
very long even just think among your
friends and relatives
all the varying degrees of concern about
coronavirus they have
for instance me i am living my life
effectively as though there is no such
thing as coronavirus
i wear the mask when i have to to go
pick up uh take out
or sometimes even sometimes i don't have
to or when i get on an airplane because
they won't let me on the airplane if i
don't wear the mask otherwise i don't
wear the mask
i don't take any sorts of precautions i
shake hands i hug people i practically
french kiss people i see on the street
okay except when they ask me not to
but other people take insane amounts of
precautions
they'll wear multiple masks they won't
see anybody they'll lock themselves up
at home
for a long time and then everybody in
the middle
taking varying degrees well i'll wear
the mask but i'll shake hands
well i'll wear two masks and i won't
touch anybody but i'll go out
and i'll touch this person i'm in this
cluster with people and it's
so awkward because in the casual social
interactions
that we have everything is now
politicized
anything you do if you go to shake a
hand if you go to say hello without a
mask on if you go to hug somebody if you
even
go to see somebody you are making a
political statement
this has been another tactic
of political correctness for about 100
years it became
clearest during the 1970s 1980s
especially through the second wave
feminists who said that the personal
is the political that ev every kind of
personal interaction
has a political connotation to it well
they succeeded they did it they've
politicized
everything now everything is open to
criticism
everything is open to public scrutiny
your most intimate interactions
how do you just restart that i don't
i don't really see how you can joy behar
over at the view
this is a really view heavy show today i
usually don't put two
view clips in a show i'm gonna where i'm
gonna have to talk to the producers
after this this is too much
for me even the stomach but joy behar
did make
a stupid point but it's thereby
therefore interesting for us to discuss
how do you send the kids back to school
how do you get this all going again
we've
basically paused our our lives for a
year but
but you can't really pause life so she
says sending kids back to school this
year
is so fraught with anxiety and
uncertainty
why not just have everyone repeat the
year is that such a far
out idea another way to put that i
suppose
is why not have everyone just circle
back just just circle back
because you can't circle back you can't
you can't
go back in time you can't repeat the
year
you can't pause life one
of the subtle temptations i've noticed
about liberalism
is that we all forget about time we all
just
we think that time doesn't matter this i
think is why you have the perpetual
adolescence
of so many people today who want to put
off
moving out of their parents house want
to put off getting married who want to
put off
having kids who want to put off buckling
down on their job who want to put off
everything and everything into the
future
they want to put all of that off because
they think time doesn't matter and so
what what's the difference
if i do these things today or i do these
things in 10 years it's no big deal
well the difference is that the death of
society
the difference is even i mean it varies
specifically on the birth rates and
marriage rates
because people keep putting these things
off so long and they ca and they put
them off more and more each year
we now have a dying population which is
one of the arguments that the open
borders left has for why we need to
flood the country with immigrants
is because otherwise we don't have
enough people to to replace the current
american population
you can't just pause things you know
this is one of the lines of
john maynard keynes the uh the liberal
economist
who said he was asked about the effects
of his policies in the short term he
said oh these are great effects in the
short term they said what about in the
long term he said in the long term we're
all dead
right at a certain point you run out of
time
you're going to tell kids who you have
psychologically tortured for a year
keeping them locked up in their little
pods away from their friends away from
learning
put their life on pause you're going to
tell them hey we're going to delay it
another year too ha ha
whatever doesn't matter just click click
pause
it's like a video game it's not a video
game life is not
a video game life is not some simulation
life is not something that can be lived
purely virtually or digitally
ordering in everything you need to your
pod doing all of your work from your
couch
never going out and living that is not
life at all
putting everything off into the future
and we're going to circle back and we're
going to circle back you have to do
things
life involves action doing things
right now but has society become so
lethargic
so decadent that we can can no longer
muster ourselves to do those sorts of
things
i sure hope not we're going to keep
trying to do things here i know you want
to do things too
let's do more things tomorrow i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show the democrats unleash
their impeachment strategy and it is all
about emotions plus
president biden moves to ram through a
1.9 trillion dollar stimulus package
doesn't sound like a lot of unity is
breaking out that's today on the ben
shapiro show give it a listen